that's a dog and this is rough good
morning Friday IRA it's been an intense
week this week and I filmed none of it
mamrie Hart and I have been having so so
many meetings for a cool project that
we're trying to get off the ground so we
have six meetings today for it so I
thought since I haven't filmed all week
I would take you through today a day in
the life of today it's 7:20 a.m. mamrie
Hart is coming to pick me up at 7:45
because we carpool because they care
about the environment
and also we don't like walking into
meetings by ourselves good morning
ghosts yes I feel the same me F gonna
steam my clothes here's our before and
here's our after ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha joke me ass memories here we go
let's go kiss me up and she got me
coffee the greatest we're on to meeting
one of six today Jesus ha ha we've made
it to meeting number one where earlier
some memory is putting on her mascara
while listening to mrs. Fergie Pussycat
Dolls ah don't you go
we're professional also we've gone down
from six meetings to five meetings so
easy day Oh as a war head southeast I'm
17 right
oh my right oh my god try everything
stop maybe has a huge complaint so I
don't know you guys can see it over
there is a billboard for the minions and
what we've learned is that the minions
of actual but they always make the
minions nature I raised that comparison
that I've never seen before until now
they look like Twinkies Twinkies with
butts while actual Twinkie
that's memories first album sexual
Twinkies oh just like that's JT's follow
album my dad's favorite song we're
getting pumped up for the next meeting
it honor how big day you're eating
number two is done
we're now heading to meeting number
three oh sorry
we just say lunch before our second no
third before our third meeting we're
here early so now we're sitting in the
car no memories taking a phone call
business business business incorporated
are you guys enjoying this video just
let's do a quick haul of memories car
what's never got in our car Yankee
Candle car freshener lavender vanilla
memory your New York Times bestseller
you get fans in the southern can tear
you all forms of caffeine coffee diet
coke ripple two copies of memories books
if you like memories children riding in
the back seat working girl's survival
stash make up way fake glasses tampon a
hairbrush all the hits you guys all the
hits what's up she's at all the member
you gotta clean these windows sorry and
those seats of that weird thing is a
tiny penis for weight how many meetings
down three edit our foreign friend a
meeting number four it's only 2:05 p.m.
stuff she's going on kids Red Bull
clocks we're really early for next
meeting but we had to valet the car so
now we're just sitting we're outside you
you outside you knew the progression of
my hair throughout the day time were
they here hello boys all day just got a
meeting number four scoring there yeah
we think one of the things like it is my
fun let me think one of these things
just might have fallen asleep while I
was talking it slowly done to close his
eyes Hey and the memory jumped in was
like oh god now we're headed to the last
one
I love his got a war best nothing is
following us what battle we are finally
done all my meetings so we're doing the
business we know how to do best
oh yeah that one's round Chiz all oh
it's the next day and I put glasses on
in an attempt to make you think I've
done something with my face I realized I
didn't fully end the video so this is me
ending the video memory knife
successfully completed five meetings
yesterday for the day before and for the
day before that hopefully soon we'll be
able to tell you what those meetings
were about a secret project to me
everything is falling apart
I don't know provide families means
diapers fiber